نحييكم مشاهدينا الى هذه التغطيه المستمره
لتطوراتي في السودان اذا هدنه تلو الاخرى
لا وجود فعليا لها على ارض الواقع في
السودان يامل السودانيون ان تتحول هدنه
حقيقيه مع دخول البلاد عيد الفطر اعاده
الله عليكم جميعا باليمن والبركات جنرال
الحرب يتبادلان الاتهامات والسودانيون
اسرى الرصاص والقذائف الطائشه حتى اشعار
اخر على طويله العشاش تمع الجنرالاني ليلا
وفي ساحه القتال تواجه صباحا ما الذي حدث
ومن اعطى الاوامر الاولى لبدء المعركه
الساعات الاخيره قبل انزلاق السودان الى
الصراع الدموي ستبقى سرا حتى الان على
الاقل حتى وان حاولت بعض المساطر كشفها
[موسيقى]
ضجيج اليات كان لم يهدا لخمسه ايام مضت
لكنه تسلل من ليله هانئه شهدت عشاء اخيرا
بين الجنارين هدوء ظاهري اخفى تحت الطاوله
مخططات جاهزه للتحشيد واطلاق الرصاصه
الاولى طرفات صراع قطع وعودا وقدمات
تنازلات بحضور وسطاء بهدف نزع فتيل
للتنافس بينهما وفق صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
وفيما كانت الالات العسكريه المتنافسه
تستعد للقتال تدفقت القوات بهدوء على
معسكرات الجيش المتنافسه في جميع انحاء
العاصمه الخرطوم بدايه الخلاف وبحسب
الصحيفه خرجت من قلق حمد المتمثل باختراق
الجيش من قبل موالينا للنظام السابق فيما
بدات المخابرات العسكريه بقياده البرهان
في اخبار المسؤولين الاجانب بان حمدت حاول
سرا استيراد طائرات مسلحه من دون طيار من
تركيا لتعزيز قوته فالخلافات لوحدت حتى
بين افراد الجيش والدعم السريع الذين
تعاملك قوتين متنافستين وليس منسجمتين ضمن
نفس الدوله لكن ما ادى الى تفاقم الخلاف
اكثر محاوله الاتفاق على دمج القوتين في
جيش واحد خصوصا ان هذه العمليه ستخرج
حمدتي الخاسر الاكبر منها
الانقلاب على الاتفاقات لم يكن الاول في
تاريخ الطرفين ففي عام 2021 فاجا
الجنرالان مبعوته الامريكي جفيف حين سقطت
الحكومه المدنيه في مسار الطريق السودان
الى الديمقراطيه عقبات كثيره وامال
الوسطاء بالتوصل لاتفاق صعبه بعد ان فجر
كل من الطرفين نواياه بوجه الاخر اياد
حمود العربيه
نقبت واطباء السودان تكشف عن ارقام صادمه
للمستشفيات التي اصبحت خارج الخدمه في ظل
استمرار للشبكات في السودان بين الجيش
وقوه دعم السريع
حرب تانيه دفعت النظام الصحي في السودان
الى حافه الانهيار لتصبح الازمه ازمتين
تزيد من ماساه الشعب السوداني الذي اتخن
بالجراح في بلد لم يعرف الاستقرار التام
منذ عقود وهو الان ضحيه السيناريو الاسوا
ارقام صادمه لعدد المستشفيات التي اصبحت
خارج الخدمه في ذروه احتياج المواطنين لها
سبعون في المئه من المرافق الصحيه اوقفت
عن العمل او اجبرت على الاغلاق بحسب نقابه
اطباء السودان فمن اصل 74 مستشفى في
العاصمه والولايات التي تقع بالقرب من
مناطق الاشتباك يوجد 52 مستشفى منها اصبحت
خارج الخدمه تماما بعد الاشتباكات الاخيره
تسعه مستشفيات منها تعرضت القصف الشديد
و19 مستشفى اخر تعرضت للاخلاء القصري ما
يعني وجود
مستشفى فقط في المنطقه تعمل بشكل كامل او
جزئي وهي الاخرى مهدده بالاغلاق في اي
لحظه بسبب انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
وانعدام الادويه وغياب الكوادر الصحيه
فهذه المرافق الطبيه تعمل بالحد الادنى من
الامكانيات والحد الاقصى من انعدام الامن
حولها
نظام الرعايه الصحيه في السودان يمكن ان
ينهر تماما تحتاج المستشفيات الى موظفين
اضافي وتحتاج الى امدادات اضافيه وتحتاج
الى امدادات دم اضافي هناك تقريبا هجوم
عسكري على عدد من المؤسسات الصحيه هناك
يعني هجوم على سيارات اسعاف وبها مرضى
وبها عاملين صحيين وعلى الرغم من تصاعد
التحذيرات الدوليه من كارثه انسانيه
وانهيار القطاع الصحي في البلاد الا ان
القتال لازال يتواصل في عاصمه السودانيه
ومدن اخرى
نتابع هذه التغطيه مع ضيفنا من برلين
دكتور اندرياس مدير معهد المشرق الالماني
ومبعوث الاتحاد الاوروبي للشرق الاوسط
لسلام سابقا سيد اندريس اهلا بك معنا مع
هذه الهدنه حتى وان كانت هشه هل تعاونون
او هل تعتقدون بان الاطر الاساسيه موجوده
لامكانيه تمديدها
لدي مال بحدوث ذلك احيانا من خلال
الدبلوماسيه
فمساله الاستمرار في المحاوله قد تؤتي
اكلها من ونعلم ان هذه المحاوله قد تكون
الثالثه
لوقف اطلاق النار
ولابد من تدخل الامم المتحده وكنا قد
سمعنا الامين العام للامم المتحده الذي
اهاب بوقف اطلاق النار المساله تتطلب وجود
ضغط دولي على الطرفين المتحاربين وانا
متفائل بان مساله وقف اطلاق النار سوف
تكون وشيكه الحدوث لكن حتى اللحظه نجد
صعوبات كبيره ولكن الضغوط قد تساعد طيب
دكتور حضرتك لك خبره في متابعه مثل هكذا
ازمات بحسب ما تتابع الان من تطورات
الانسب من هي جهات القادره على تقديم حل
يثبت هذه الهدنه وخاصه
يمكن من خلالها ان تؤمن ممرات لتمكين
تقديم المساعدات
هناك طريقه الطريقه الاولى
لا بد من وقف القتال في المقام الاول هذه
هي الخطوه الاولى
واذا لم يتحقق هذا الامر لا بد من التوجه
لمحاوله اخرى الممرات الانسانيه قد لا
يكون منها جدوى اذا لم يتوقف القتال واذا
لم يحدث هذا الامر فلا بد من العمل على
طرح مساله
اقدام المنظمات الانسانيه على المطالبه
بالممرات الانسانيه الامر الاكثر اهميه هو
ان نعمل على الاستمرار في التحاور
المعطرفي النزاع من اجل ان نشرح لهما بانه
مال لن يحقق اهدافهم من خلال القوه
العسكريه
وندرك تماما ان سبب هذا القتال
لابد له ان
يرمى منه الى تحقيق الى توحيد صفوفي
العسكري وهذه المساله صعبه وكلنا ندرك بان
كل من الجنرلين المتحاربين يدركان بانه لن
يحقق هذا الهدف ولابد من فرض ضغوط متزايده
من اسره الدوليه ولهذا سبب ان الامم
المتحده كانت تسعى لتحقيق هذا المارب
الاتحاد
الاوروبي طورات ومعني
خاصه ايجاد
حلول
في هذه المرحله على وجه التحديد فان
الاتحاد الاوروبي لا نجده الا
خلف ابواب مغلقه لكن
الجامعه الدول العربيه والامم المتحده
ودول الاتحاد الافريقي كلها قد يكون لها
دورا مهم وهذه جهات فاعله
يمكنها ان تحقق نوعا من الوسط اذا ما كان
هناك الحاجه لدعم اضافي بمقدوره الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان يفعل ذلك لكن
دعونا نرى كيف سوف
تتمخض الامور ندرك بان بعض منازل السفراء
الاوروبيين قد تعرضت للهجوم في الخرطوم
ولكن تلك الجهات الثلاثه التي ذكرتها قد
تكون مهملاء وفي ذات الوقت على الاتحاد
الاوروبي حاله حال المنظمات
والدوليه الكبرى ودول الاخرى سوف تقدم اي
مساعدات قد يفرضها الواقع لكن الاعتماد في
المقام الاول على تلك الجهات التي ذكرتها
سلفا دكتور اندريس قلت منذ قليل بان عددا
من منازل السفراء الاوروبيين تعرضوا للقصف
في هذه الحاله وفي مثل هكذا ازمات كيف
تتعامل اوروبا كيف يتعامل الاتحاد
الاوروبي مع هذه الايام الاولى من
الاشتباكات
هناك طريقه اولا
على حاله وغراري الدول الاخرى فاننا نرغب
بحمايه المواطنين الاوروبيين المانيا
حاولت اجلاء ما يصل الى 150
من رعاياها الالمان من الخرطوم لكنها لم
تفلح بذلك بسبب تعطل المطر وحركه الطائرات
فمن جهه السفراء لابد عليهم ان يعملوا على
حمايه مواطنيهم وفي وايضا لابد ان يتم توص
الى الى حقيقه مفادها ان الحل العسكري لن
يفلح بل هو الحل السياسي ومن المفاجئ ان
نرى ان استمرار هذا الصراع قد
لابد له ان يدفع
بضغطه من الاسره الدوليه للحديث لهما
والتاكيد بان الاسره الدوليه لا ترغبوا
باستمرار هذا القتال وتعمل على تحقيق ذلك
من خلال فرض الضغوط والشرح للاطراف
المتحاربه بان هذا لن يفضي لاي مصلحه يمكن
تحقيقها
هذه هي طرق الاتصالات التي يجب ان يتم
تنفيذها مع الاطراف المتحاربه احيانا في
ان مثل هذه
المصادمات يتم فيها التركيز على انجازات
يمكن تحقيقها على الامد القصير لكن علينا
ان نتذكر ان هناك مصالح اخرى لذا من
الضروره ان يتم التواصل مع الاطراف
المتحاربه وشرح كل تلك الامور لهم نعم
وضحت الفكره والشكرك جزيلا شكر على
المشاركه من برلين الدكتوره اندرياس مدير
معهد المشرق الالماني ومبعوثه للاتحاد
الاوروبي لشرق الاوسط لسلام سابقا شكرا
جزيلا لك نتابع مشاهدينا كل هذه التطورات
تعلمون بان الشق الانساني جد مهما نسال عن
هذا الموضوع ضيفنا عبر الهاتف من الخرطوم
الدكتور هيثم ابراهيم وزير الصحه
السودانيه
معالي الوزير اهلا بك معنا مبدئيا لو سمحت
لي ضعنا في اطار اخر الارقام هناك ارقام
مفزعه لتوقف اكثر من 70% من المستشفيات
تؤكد لنا ذلك وما هي الحصيله النهائيه
شكرا جزيلا في البدايه نترحم على من فقدنا
ونساه ربنا ان يحفظ العباد والبلاد وينعاد
العيد على الامم السودانيه وهي في سلم
وامانه
عبر الغرفه المركزيه لعمليات الطوارئ
الصحيه في السودان والهبه تمثل الوزاره
الاتحاديه مع مدراء عموم الصحفي كل
الولايات السودان
نتلقى المعلومات الصحيه
والمستشفيات التي تعاثرت في كل الولايات
السودان على مدار
اشد العمومه عدد من الولايات السودان
تعشرت
الحرب والنزاع
بصوره كبيره ولايه الخرطوم بالتاكيد
ومواصفات الصحيه واربعه من ولايات دارفور
والولايه الشماليه والولايه الشمال كردفان
بصوره كليه في ولايه الخرطوم تاشرت
المستشفيات فيها حوالي
125 مستشفى ما بين القطاعين العام والخاص
تاثرت المستشفيات المركزيه بصوره اساسيه
اللي هي فيها النقاط الاشتباك ابي صوره
كبيره في مركز الخرطوم والمستشفيات التي
تتعرضت الكيبلات الكهرباء للقصف والضرب او
خزانات المياه وصارت فيها صعوبه في
التشغيل وفي صعوبه في الوصول لها كذلك
للكوادر الطبيه وصعوبه ايصال الطبيه لها
والامداد الغذائي في منطقه مركزية دكتور
صحيح ولكن ان وجدنا الوقوف على بعض
الارقام دكتور من بين 125 مستشفى داخل
الخرطوم ما هو عدد المستشفيات التي بقيت
تعمل
تقرير اليوم الاحصائي من كل الولايات
السودان وصلت للمستشفيات كلها حوالي
3,500 اصابه في كل ولايات السودان وعدد
الوفيات تم رفضها اكثر من 300 وفاه في كل
مستشفى السودان تقريبا المستشفيات التي
تاثرت زي ما ذكرتها المركزيه
هذه المستشفيات حاليا خرجت من الخدمه ووسط
الطوارئ استعاده بالبديل مباشره على اساس
ان المستشفيات الطرفيه في الولايه
الصحيه كما نشرها على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي انها تعمل وتشتغل وبالتالي
بدانا السقف انها تشتغل بكفاءه العادي على
اساس ان
ها ست المستشفيات التخصصيه زي المستشفيات
الاطفال ومستشفيات الولاده تكون شغاله
وعامله من هنا صحيح ولكن دكتور نقص فيما
يخص ماذا بالتحديد
النقص بصوره اساسيه عندنا
حتكون عندنا مساله مرض الاورام لانه
مستشفى الذره هو المستشفى المركز الرئيسي
الوحيد في وسط الخرطوم في منطقه الاشتباك
ما في بديل له حيكون في اشكاليه مساله
الغسيل الكلى مراكز الموزعه في الولايات
الخرطوم في الولايات المختلفه بصوره كويسه
في مبادرات كثيره جدا ونحن من هنا نشكر
الكوادر الطبيه
جميعا على همتهم
وتواصلهم مع عبر المراكز الصحيه او
المستشفيات الطرفيه جنبه هنا او
بالمعالجات عبر الوسائط التواصل الاجتماعي
عندنا مشكله في الامداد حاليا المشكله في
اصابات وليس في الامدادات الامداد واذا
استطالت المساله بتاعه
يحصل لنا انقطاع في بعض الادويه الاساسيه
لكن حاليا الامداد الموجود في الامدادات
محتاجين انه يصل لمواقع المستشفيات كذلك
محتاجين لمساله تامين وصول الكوادر الطبيه
واجاده مسارات لانه برضو هناك عدد من
الكوادر الطبيه تعمل في هذه المستشفيات
خمسه او سته ايام متصله بالليل والنهار
مقدمين العمل الانساني الكبير والجليل
فبالتالي احنا محتاجين لتامين مسارات
الاطباء وسعرات الامداد وايصال الوقود
للمستشفيات التامه تحديدا بصوره اساسيه
كما نحتاج كذلك لمساله ضرو
ريه والامدادات الطبيه لانه عندنا بعض
يعني عندنا مخزون كبير جدا في جنوب دارف
مخالا لمنتخابات الطبيه تعرض بالكامل
لعمليات للحرق بصوره نهائيه فبالتالي
حمايه المواصفات الصحيه والمستشفيات
المسارات خاصه المسارات الاسعافات
للمرضى وتامين وصول الكوادر الطبيه
والغذاءات لهذه
الدكتور هناك بعض الاخبار المتفرقه نود
التاكد منها لو سمحتي ساعود لموضوع
الممرات ولكن كانت هناك اخبار تتعلق
باستخدام بعض المستشفيات
اماكن
لتجميع الاسلحه فيها تنفي ذلك تماما
لم يصل الينا ان هنالك مستشفيات اصبحت
مواقع لتجميع الاسلحه المستشفيات كل
المستشفيات بالتابعه يتم اخلاء الكوازن
الطبيه منها والمرضى وانا شهيت خلال عدد
من المستشفيات في وسط الخرطوم نتيجه
لصعوبه العمل في هذه المستشفيات لانها
توجد في مواقع اشتباك بين الطرفين قريبه
جدا من المواقع الرصاص والضرب تعرضت هذه
المستشفيات لضرب خزانات المياه
وضرب ولاده الكهرباء وبالتالي اضطرينا
لنقل وتحويل المرطبه الاسعافات لمستشفيات
اخرى موجوده في ولايه الخرمه تقول دكتور
بان الكميات متوفره ولكن طرق الامداد او
طريقه امداد او طريقه ايصال الكوادر وكذلك
حتى المساعده الطبيه هي الغير متوفره هل
تعملون على ذلك ومع اي جهات وكيف تعملون
على ذلك يعني
حضرتك هل تناقشون هذا الموضوع مع مؤسسات
مع منظمات لتمكين هذه
الامدادات من الوصول الى مستحقها
تصحيح
الامداد الدوائي ليس متوفر بالصوره
الكافيه ولكن نحن نعمل من المخزون
الاستراتيجي الموجود وبالتالي
هددنا انه الايصال هذا المخزون
للمستشفيات والولايات وحددنا قوائم وحوجه
اساسيه محدده للادويه الاساسيه وللمعينات
الاساسيه في مثل هذه الحالات للطوارئ
وشاركنا هذه
الاحصائيات والادويه المطلوبه مع عدد من
سفراء ومع منظمات الدوليه على راسها منظمه
الصحه العالميه اللي هم بيدوروا برضه
واتواصلوا معانا وذكروا منهم عندهم في
مخازنهم الموجوده داخل السودان جزء من
الامداد يحتاجون لتامين الوصول له وكذلك
في فرص مين لانداد دوائي وصلتنا بعض
المبادرات من الاشياء الاساسيه المحتاجين
نرتبها لوصولا السودان المساله الاولى
الموجود محتاج يصل والمساله الثانيه في
حاله
سر الامداد لا يكفي لفتره طويله وبالتالي
جهزنا بعض القوائم الاساسيه اللي بنحتاجه
من كل الشركاء في منظمات الدوليه منظمات
المجتمع المدني القطاع الخاص حاجات احنا
شاكرينهم لانهم برضو بيعدوا دور كبير جدا
في ظل هذه الظروف وكذلك من الدول على اساس
انها تكون الحوجه او المساعده حسب
هذه المعلومه فيما فيما يتماثل هذا الدور
تقول حاضر بانكم تتعاونون مع منظمات
اغاثيه دوليه واقليميه كيف
تم التواصل المباشر اول حاجه في غرفه
العمليات المركزيه يوجد ممثلين لهذه
المنظمات عندنا في السودان
منظمه الصحه العالميه اليونسيف الاي سي ار
سي يوجد ممثلين لهم معنا في الغرفه
المركزيه
للطوارئ الصحيه في السودان
ونتبادل المعلومات وبالتالي هم بيدور
ياخذوا الحوجه الاساسيه للنظام الصحي في
السودان والارقام الاساسيه
ومعاه مكاتبهم الرئيسيه وتلقينا رساله من
مدير منظمه الصحه العالميه للوقوف مع
السودان والنظام الصحي في هذه الظروف
وانقاذ حياه الناس ولكن هذه المساعدات لا
زالت تصلكم من داخل السودان ويتعذر دخول
المزيد منها من خارج السودان صحيح مع تعطل
خدمه المطار
تحاولون ذلك
والتواصل والمناشدات والنداءات لانه ضروره
الاسعاف العربات المعلمه للصحه والامدادات
الطبيه
بتسهيل ممراتها تسهيل وصولها تسهيل
وصول الكوادر الطبيه حاولنا برضو توزيع
الكوادر الطبيه بقدر الامكان في اماكنهم
على اساس انه تقليل
المساله التنقل ووجدنا استجابه كبيره جدا
حاجه الكوادر الطبيه والتفانينهم باتجاه
العمل وانقاذ حياه الناس في المستشفيات
المختل برضو هنالك تاكيد مع الولايات
القريبه ولايه الجزيره ولايه القضارف
باعتبارها من عدد كبير جدا والمواطنين
انتقلوا الى هذه
الايات قري
با ممكن
برضه
هذه الولايات للعلاج وفي تنسيق زي ما ذكرت
لك في الغرفه الطوارئ المركزيه انها بتمثل
فيها في المعلومات المدراء عموم الصحه في
كل ولايات السودان دكتور حدثني منذ قليل
عن رساله وصلتكم من الامم المتحده هل هناك
وعود في هذا الاطار اما فيما يخص
المساعدات او كذلك فيما يخص فتح ممرات
امنه
والله هي عباره عن مناشدات من منظمه الصحه
العالميه
لحمايه المؤسسات الصحيه والكوادر الصحيه
وضروره العمل
عن مساعده السودان في هذا الوضع الحرجي
والصعيدكم انتم يعني
بايصال المساعدات الطبيه
لديها بعض المخزون في مكاتبها داخل في
مخازنه داخل السودان ويجب الترتيب
للمستشفيات والاستفاده من الاضافه لذلك
عدد من المنظمات الوطنيه برضها عندها في
مخاذنا
في السودان عباره عن
الادوات الجراحيه الاساسيه وادوات
الاسعافات الاوليه موجوده في مخازنها زي
الهلال الاحمر برضو في ترتيب هذه
المستشفيات هذه الترتيبات بمجهودكم الخاص
دكتور او هناك جهات دوليه تؤمن كذلك تقف
معكم تساعدكم في هذا الاطار
كل هذا العمل حتى الان مع عبر
الغرفه المركزيه الممثله من الصحه
الاتحاديه ومدراء عموم الطوارئ الصحيه
ومدراء صحفي الولايات هل هناك مقاطع
تعزة
والكوادر الصحيه في عدد كبير جدا من
المستشفيات
للعمل وبرضو تطور المساهمه في مساعده
ايصال
المعينات هل هناك مناطق فيها جرحى وقتلى
تعذر الوصول لها بحسب ما وردك من اخبار
الصحيه فاذا كان في مناطق خارج المواسطه
صحيه او جرحه خارجه مؤسسيحيه من الصعب
تصنع الاخبار عنها لكن كل ما يصلنا هو
عباره عن نقاط
الاتصالات الصحيه او عبر الاسعاف في ولايه
السودان المختلفه حضرتك وزير صحه وتعلم
اكثر منا كلنا بان السودان اساسا كان يعيش
ماساه وهناك مخيمات هي نفسها مش في
الخرطوم خارج الخرطوم ولكن هي نفسها تحتاج
لمساعدات وتحتاج للتغذيه للتطبيب الى اخره
مع هذه الازمه الجديده كيف بات الوضع
دكتور حدثنا اكثر كذلك عن هذه المناطق
التي تعيش اساسا ازمه قبل انطلاق هذه
الاشتباكات
بالتاكيد الموضوع
بالتاكيد استطاله الحرب في هذه الظروف
ووضع السودان المعروف
ووضع المعسكرات اللي هي
الحكم سعاده كبيره جدا من المنظمات بتساعد
السودان في العمل في هذه المعسكرات لكن
اخشى انه هذه المنظمات كذلك تجد صعوبه في
ايصال الخدماتها وصعوبه في جلب الدعم لهذه
المعسكرات نقطه ثانيه برضو استطاله الحرب
قد تكون لها تاخيراتها الاخرى على السودان
في جانب الاوبئه والطوارئ الصحيه السودان
معروف فيه الحميات ونحن على مقبل مدخل
الخريف فبالتالي مثل هذه الظروف وتوقف
العمليات صحه البيئه قد يكون لها اثر صحي
كارثي كبير جدا في الفتره القادمه اضافه
لذلك اذا استطالت فتره الحرب وتاثرت
المرافق الصحيه في مراكز الاساسيه مساله
التطعيم وخدمات صحه الامم والاطفال
والامراض المزمنه بامراض
السكري والضغط وغيره قد تتفاقم المساله
فبيبدا المناشد الاساسيه هي بضروره انهاء
هذه الازمه السرعه المطلوبه حتى نتمكن من
استعاده النظام الصحي لاستجابته للطوارئ
ومعالجه الحالات
شكر على المشاركه وكل ما تفضلت به من
معلومات عبر الهاتف من الخرطوم الدكتور
هيثم ابراهيم وزير الصحه السودانيه شكرا
جزيلا
نتابع دائما مع
استطلاعنا للصوره وما ورد كذلك من اخبار
مع زميلتنا من الرياض الى يعقوب مديره
مكتب العربيه في السودان اهلا بك معنا
نعلم بانه تعذر عليك دخول السودان وان
تكوني على الميدان لتكوني اكثر قربا من
الصوره ولكن الاكيد كذلك بانك تتابعين
لحظه بلحظه ما يحدث في داخل السوداني
لنا هذه الهدنه هل هناك بوادر هل هناك
محاولات لتمديدها بحسب ما وردك من معلومات
حتى الان
اهلا بك يا عزيزتي ريم كما ذكرتي في البدء
لست انا فقط كثيرين نحاول الدخول الى
السودان وفي ذاك الوقت كثيرون في السودان
يحاولون الان الخروج من نسبه لهذا القصف
الذي اصبح في العاصمه الخرطوم في احياء
كثيره ومدن كثيره لم تسلم حتى منها
المناطق السكنيه حاله الدعره التي يعيشها
المواطنون السوداني تجعلهم الان يحاولون
النزوح والسفر خارج العاصمه الى الولايات
ومن ثم بعدها ربما الى دول الجوار الاوضاع
يا ريم هي سيئه استمعت لما قاله وزير
الصحه هو تحدث عن الجانب الصحي عن نقصا
ادويه والمستلزمات الطبيه والكوادر كذلك
هناك اغلاق لمستشفيات لدينا مراسلين
مدانيين تجولوا في بعض المستشفيات
الحكوميه هي مغلقه مغلقه اما لنقص الكوادر
والمستلزمات او لخشيه ان يتم اقتحامها
وتكسير ما فيها او للخوف والقلق ايضا
الاوضاع ايضا يا ريم هي في ما يتعلق
بالجانب
السياسي التي الذي سالتي عنه قبل قليل لا
توجد في الحقيقه بوادر الا مجرد وعود
ومجرد تعاقدات مثلا من الاتراك بالالتزام
بهدنه او انهم يرحبون بهذا الوقف ولكن على
الميزان وعلى ارض الواقع لا تظهر مبادئ
للتفاؤل ربما الان فقط بعد اعلان العيد
غدا في كثير من الدول العربيه ومن بينها
طبعا السودان ربما يساهم هذا على الاقل في
تقليد حده التوتر والقصف المتواصل الذي
يقام وسط الخرطوم بعض المناطق في ام درمان
وكذلك بعض المناطق في بحري وهي المناطق
اصلا صحيح انها ماهوله بالسكر ولكن
يتضررون من من الشظايا من شظايا القصف
هناك رصاص يدخل الى بعض المنازل هناك حاله
القلق لذلك هذه الاوضاع الان تؤثر على
الجميع في العاصمه وفي العاده كانت
الاوضاع تسوء في الولايات السودانيه وتكون
هادئه ومستقره في الخرطوم الان اصبح العكس
لذلك قد يتفاعل فقط السودانيون بان يكون
غدا اول ايام العيد ان يحاول الطرفين
الالتزام ظهورنا اطول من الثلاثه ساعات او
من 24 ساعه صحيح لنا انت اقرب منا للصوره
الحقيقيه في داخل السوداني واعلم كذلك
بظروف وبطبيعه هذا الملف هل تعتقدين لينا
بان هناك طرف داخل السوداني او هل يوجد
طرف داخل السوداني قادر على ان يتوسط بين
الطرفين لمحاوله تمديد هذه التهدئه سواء
ان كان سياسي او كذلك ينتمي لاي جهاز
عسكريه
كان ريم قبل ان يندلع هذا الاشتباك كان
يمكن ان تسهم بعض الاطراف في التهدئه ولكن
شكل القصف وشكل الدمار يشير بصوره واضحه
الى صعوبه ان يتوسط الان سودانيون للتهدئه
بين الطرفين لماذا لان هناك اتهامات من كل
طرف بان هناك قوه سياسيه معينه وجهاد
معينه هي اقرب للطرف الاخر ربما كانت
الوساطه الدوليه رغم رفض الجيش السوداني
وقال انها مشكله سودانيه وازمه سودانيه
ولكن اعتقد ان الاقرب هو ليست تدخل
الخارجي انما الوساطه التي يمكن ان يقودها
الخارج او بعض الدول بالتحديد في الداخل
السوداني كان هناك الكثير من الانشقاقات
كثير من الاتهامات ليس فقط للتباين وجهات
النظر انما اصبحت احزاب قوه سياسيه تقف مع
الجيش في المقابل اصبحت هناك احزاب وقوه
سياسيه تقف مع الدعم السريع هذا بالنسبه
للقوى السياسيه وكذلك للمجموعات العسكريه
ولكن بالنسبه للقاعده الشعبيه لذا نحن ما
نتابعه على الاقل من خلال الصور من خلال
قراءتنا ومتابعتنا لمواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وكان
السودانيين هناك حاله ملل من هذه الصراعات
المستمره هناك حرب اهليه لم ينساها
السودانيون وبالتالي ان يكون هناك حتى
هناك وسم هاشتاق على تويتر لا مع فلان ولا
فلان يعني لا حمادتي ولا البرهان نحن نود
تحقيق السلام في داخل السوداني هذه الصوره
الى اي مدى تؤثر كذلك على هذه الاشتباكات
تؤثر على هذه الازمه ايجابيا اتحدث
ربما ريم هي تؤثر ايضا على مستقبل قيادات
الصف الاول مقبلا في السودان وماذا
امكانيه ان يلعبوا دور مؤثر في السودان
هذا الهاشتاق الذي تحدثتي انت عنه واشرت
اليه هو الان موجود صحيح انه في وقت سابق
تجدين كثير من فئات الشارع السوداني تقف
مع مع الجيش ومع قيادات الجيش في فتره
اخرى اصبح الشارع السوداني يقف مع الجيش
كمؤسسه عسكريه وليس معاقادته في المقابل
هناك بعض او فئات من الشارع السوداني ترى
ان الدعم السريع هو يقف مع قوه سياسيه وان
الجيش لا يرغب بتسليم السلطه كل هذه
الانشقاقات والتباينات والتوترات التي
ارتفعت في داخل في داخل السوداني وفي
الشارع السوداني
اسهما بصوره مباشره ان لا يثق هؤلاء في في
القاده فيما يمكن ان يتحقق في المستقبل من
السلام لكن رغم ذلك هما الان يهمهم ايقاف
هذه الحرب ان يتوقف ان تتوقف اصوات الرصاص
ان يستطيع السوداني ممارسه حياتهم بشكل
طبيعي لانها ساءت اكثر مما كانت عليه في
السابق كان هناك تدهور صحي تدهور في
الخدمات تدهور في التعليم لكن كل هذا
الامر مع هذا الحرف اصبح او وصل الى درجه
سيئه بالتالي الان كل الاهتمام وكل
الاعماق تصب بان تتوقف هذه الحرب حتى يتم
اصلاح ما افسد خلال الفتره القليله
الماضيه عزيزتي لنا مره اخرى كل عام وانت
بخير وان شاء الله عيد الفطرين عاد عليك
على كل اهلك وعلى السودان كذلك بالتهدئه
والسلام شكرا جزيلا لكنا يعقوب مديره مكتب
العربيه في السودان
مشاهدينا الخلاف على السلطه لم تحتويه
صداقه العقدين تصاعدات عده بدات منذ عام
2021 زادها اتساعا دمج قوات الدعم السريع
بالجيش ما دفع بعلاقه عمرها سنوات بين
البرهان وحماتي للانهيار نتابع
عشرون عاما قضاياها رفيقي درب وسلاح خندق
واحد جمع الضابطين اللذين عمل جنبا الى
جنب في ميادين القتال قبل ان يخرق صمت
المماطله بالاتفاق رصاص اوقع وحده الصف
وارهق صداقه امتدت لعقدين من الزمن
ابن بادر بسيط
نشاتها في خامج السودان كل منهما يتحذر من
مدرسه قتاليه مغيره صرامه عسكريه وتمرس
بمطارده الحركات المسلحه جمعت بينهما
ضرورات مرحليه تتقاطع مع ظروف حرب دارفور
عام 2003 فهناك كان اللقاء الاول بين عبد
الفتاح البرهان ومحمد حمدان دقلو حينها
كان البرهان ضابطا بسلاح المشاته في مقادح
متي عشرات المسلحين لحمايه الاهالي وقوافل
لتجارتهم هل تقاسم مهامه وذخيره صعدت
بعدها العلاقه تدريجيا وان عن بعد قبل ان
يدور الزمن ويعيدهما لصداره المشهد عام
تحالف عسكري سياسي هذه المره بهدف اسقاط
حكم البشير تحت ضغط الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
ليمتطيا معا صهوه فتره انتقاليه كان يؤمل
منها قياده البلاد نحو الديمقراطيه
مجلس عسكري تلاه اخر عرف بمجلس السياده
الانتقالي تراسهما تباعا البرهان منتقيا
في كل مره صديقه للنيابه عنه
هذه العلاقه ظلت خاليه من التشويش لحين
اصطدامها بحائط رمي المسؤوليه عن فض
اعتصام القياده عام 2019
فبرزت شروخ داخل المكون العسكري تلملمت
على الاقل ظاهريا
وصف بانقلاب الخامس والعشرين من اكتوبر ثم
تاسف عنه وامتعض من اعاده قائد الجيش
لعناصر النظام السابق للسلطه واتسعت
الفجوه اكثر مع توقيع الاتفاق الايطالي
والخلاف على الجداول الزمنيه لدمج قوات
الدعم السريع بالقوات المسلحه
مشاهدينا ننتقل لمتابعه هذه الكلمات
من اجل سلامتي موظفي السفاره هناك وكما
رايتم ان البنتاغون كان قد اعلن بان قد
يكون الوضع
يملي نقل بعض القوات
العسكريه في حاله كان هناك حاجه ملحه
لاجلاء الموظفين الدبلوماسيين لكن الان
الامر الملح هو ان يعمل الطرفان على وقف
اطلاق نار من اجل السماح للمساعدات
الانسانيه للوصول لتصل الى الاشخاص
المحتاجين اليها في ظل نقصي الغذاء والماء
والوضع يبدو قاتما في الخرطوم وانهيب
بالطرفين بوقف العمليات القتاليه
هل هناك اي قرارات من قبيل العقوبات
لدينا دائما جمله من الادوات التي يمكن
استخدامها من اجل الزامي الطرفين على وقف
العنف لكن
قد يكونوا لوزاره الدفاع
اطار عمل في هذا الخصوص علينا ان نضمن بان
الكافه القدرات سوف تكون متوفره في حاله
الحاجه اليها
قد يكون من المبكر
قد يكون من المبكر ان
ابدا بالسؤال
سوف سوف يكون هناك تعاون عسكري بين كوريا
الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده في في عقاب
التدريبات العسكريه المنتظره
اذا المشاهدين سنكتفي بهذه الكلمه البيت
الابيض يقول ان العقوبات ضمن الخيارات
المطروحه
للمساعده في وقف النار بالسودان ولكن قبل
هذا العاجل كنا نتابع كذلك عاجل اخر يقول
فيه انه يجب ان يتوقف الاقتتال بين
الطرفين لنتمكن كذلك من ايصال هذه
المساعدات سنعود لهذه الكلمه مشاهدينا
ولكن مع اكثر تفاصيل بعد قليل سنتابع مع
اخبار ذات سيلا حيث اصبحت مشاهد للشبكات
واطلاق النار في السودان مالوفه مقاطع
فيديو انتشرت تظهر مواطنين يفطرون على
اصوات اطلاق النار الكثيف فيما جلس اخرون
يتابعون المواجهات بين الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع نتابع
ليست مشاهد من فيلم سينمائي ولا مقاطع
مركبه في السودان اضحت اصوات اطلاق النار
مالوفه الى درجه التطبيع معها بعد يوم
طويل من الصيام مواطنون سودانيون يفطرون
على اصوات اطلاق النار الكثيف والقتال
المستعر بين الجيش والدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
قبل ذلك جلس اخرون متابعين للاشتباكات
وكان الامر يتعلق بمسرح في الهواء الطلق
غير ان الكلفه البشريه للوضع ترتفع يوما
بعد يوم
مشاهدينا نستكمل دائما استطلاع الاوضاع من
الخرطوم ورسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي سالم
اهلا بك معنا
الدخان لازال يتصاعد اصوات الرصاص لا زالت
مستمره قبل نهايه الهدنه وحتى بعد نهايتها
كيف هي الصوره وكيف هو وقع الاشتباكات في
داخل الخرطوم
احيانا خلال هذا اليوم كان اخرها عصرها
هذا اليوم كانت هناك اصوات لمضادات
الطائرات تنطلق هنا في منطقه البحري في
مناطق متفرقه من منطقه بحري وكذلك في شرق
النيل في منطقه بحري كذلك بالقرب
الخرطوم
المنشيه في الجهه الشرقيه منه في جهه بحري
كانت هناك ايضا مضادات الطائرات وكانت
هناك طائرات
تتبع للقوات الجويه السودانيه وهي تمثل
بعض الحملات التي تستهدف فيها المواقع
التي تتمركز فيها قوات ان تعمل سريع وكانت
مضادات الطائرات كذلك والمدافع الثقيله في
مختلف انحاء ولايه الخرطوم اليوم الا ان
هذه
الاصوات كانت في مناطق محدده في الخرطوم
وبحري واندرمان في المناطق التي
المواطن السوداني او مواطن الولايات
الخرطوم يستمع اليها من هذه المنطقه
هذه المناطق المحدده تحدثنا عنها اكثر
يعني نتحدث عن محيط القياده العامه ولكن
نتحدث عن مراكز او مناطق اخرى اين تتركز
هذه الاشتباكات بالتحديد
لعب ربما محيط القياده العامه اليوم هو
الاقل في هذه الاصوات وربما كانت اكثر في
بحري وفي ام درمان البحري في منطقه
المظلات بالقرب من جسر الشنبات الربط بين
البحري وام درمان في هذه المنطقه منطقه
المظلات اجتمعنا الى مدافع ثقيله وخفيفه
وكذلك في كارفور كذلك استمع اليها في شرق
النيل في جهه شرق النيل او محيط شرق النيل
في تلك المناطق عليها في محيط الاذاعه
والتلفزيون والمهندسين كذلك في تلك
المناطق استمع للمواطلون الى اصوات لمدافع
واصوات لتبادل لاطلاق النار على كل سنبقى
في متابعه كل هذه التطورات اكتفي معك بهذا
القدر من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سلم
الهاشمي شوكليلا لك
ومشاهدينا عن اعداد الضحايا قالت منظمه
الصحه العالميه انها رصدت مقتله 330 شخصا
واصابه
3200 اخرين جراء او اخرين جراء الاشتباكات
في السودان الصحه العالميه دعت جميع
الاطراف في السودان لهدنه انسانيه للسماح
للمواطنين بالحصول على رعايه الطبيه كما
اكدت المنظمه انها ستجلب المزيد من
التجهيزات الطبيه لدى السماح بذلك مشيره
الى نقص الحاد في امتداد المياه والوقود
في المنشات الصحيه بالسودان نقابه اطباء
السودان قالت ان 52 مستشفى من اصل 74
متوقفه عن الخدمه
يعاني الوضع الصحي في السودان من تدهور
كبير في ظل تعرض مستشفيات للقصف وانقطاع
الكهرباء عنها ياتي هذا خاصه وان القطاع
الصحي في هذا البلد يعاني من الهشاشه منذ
سنوات عديده
[موسيقى]
ووسط ظلام الاقتتال يبرز شعاع امل في
السودان في احد المستشفيات المتوقف عن
الخدمه ولد طفل بعد ان تمكن طاقه منطبي من
اجراء هذه الولاده المستعجله في ظل اضطرار
الناسى للمكوث في منازلهم بسبب القصف
العشوائي هي المستمر الفرح بالمولود كان
منسوبه مرتفعا
بين ثنايا الحروب والمواجهه والاقتتال
تبرز اخبار الباعثه للامل في نفوس الناس
من
رحم المعاناه ولد طفل سوداني باحد
المستشفيات شجاعه كبيره من طواقم طبيه
متطوعه عرضت حياتها للخطر لاجراء هذه
الولاده المستعجله الفرح بهذا المولود لم
يكن عاديا ربما لانه يمثل ولاده السودان
جديد بعد نهايه الازمه في مخيله
السودانيين على الاقل
حذر قيادي في قوى الحريه والتغيير
السودانيه في تصريحات لصحيفه السودان من
ان استمرار الحرب سيؤدي الى مواصفه بتدخل
اقليمي واسع يحول السودان الى دويلات
متنازعه ونقلت الصحيفه عن القيادي بالحريه
والتغيير ياسر عرمان قوله ان الحاله
الوحيده في السودان هو تشكيل كتله مدنيه
صلبه ومتحده ضد الحرب مشددا على انه من
دون ذلك ستتمزق البلاد دون رحمه
بحث وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ونظيره البريطاني
تطورات الاوضاع في السودان وذلك خلال
اتصال هاتفي ودعا الوزيران الى وقف اطلاق
النار والتصعيد العسكري وانهاء العنف
وحمايه المدنيين وتوفير الممرات الامنه
للعمليات الانسانيه
بحث رئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي مع
رئيس الاماراتيه الشيخ محمد بن زايد
التطورات في السودان السيسي ومحمد بن زايد
دعياييل وقف التصعيد والعوده للحوار في
السودان كما اكد ضروره العوده للمسار
السياسي في السودان
نفى رئيس وزراء اثيوبيا باحمد نشره قواته
في المناطق الحدوديه لبلادهم مع السودان
وقال ان اثيوبيا لا ترغب انتهاز الظروف
الحاليه التي يمر بها السودان واشار الى
ان قضيه الحدوث مع السودان تحل عبر الحوار
مشكله كبيره نازله
حتى الناس ما لاقيه يعني حتى الموت الصحه
في المحلات التجاريه والم
رجعوا يستخدموا الابار
خاصه
وهي مياه برضو مش صالحه للشرب بقدر ما هي
ممكن يتم استخدامك اشياء ثانيه
مشاهدينا قبل المتابعه الى هذه الصور التي
وردتنا منذ قليل وهذه صور لجنازه احد
القتلى هناك صور في ما قبل الجنازه ولكن
هذه تبدو صور من داخل منزل احد القتلى هم
بالمئات وعشرات الجرح كذلك نستمر
[موسيقى]
الله
نكفي بهذا القدر ونعود لاستكمال بقيه
المواضيع ذات الصله يكاد ان ينتهي اليوم
والسادس المعارك في السودان وحتى الان لم
يظهر قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
بشكل علني كما انا عبد الفتاح البرهان
قائد الجيش
ظهر لمره واحده في مقطع قصير من احد غرف
العمليات
على مدار ايام سيطر عثمان على المسامع عبد
الفتاح البرهان قائد الجيش السوداني ومحمد
حمدان
قائد قوات الدعم السريع القوات التي تخضع
لكل منهما تخوض معارك محتدمه في شوارع
الخرطوم احتراب اندلعت شرارته الاولى يوم
الخامس عشر من ابريل ولا تزال راحه دائره
تساؤلات تتنامى مع تطور المواجهه لعل
ابرزها لماذا يتجنب الخصمان الظهور لا احد
يمكن ان يجزم بمقر اقامه الخصمين خاصه ان
كل طرف يصر على الحسم فهي معركه وجوديه او
صفريه بقاء احد الطرفين يعني ان الاخر خرج
من المعادله السودانيه
عصر اليوم الاول من المعارك
ظهر البرهان في الخرطوم لخمسه عشره ثانيه
في مقطع مصور يرجح ان يكون التقط داخل
احدى غرف العمليات العسكريه من مقر
القياده العامه وبجواره قائد الحرس
الرئاسي ومجموعه من العسكريين يتابعون
الاحداث المشتعله ثلاثه اماكن قد يوجد
فيها البرهان داخل الخرطوم اما في قصر
الضيافه او القصر الجمهوري او القياده
العامه للجيش وهي الاماكن التي حاولت قوات
الدعم السريع السيط عليها وفي السابع عشر
من ابريل قصفت قوات الجيش احد المقرات في
حي المطار حيث رجحت القوات المسلحه وجود
قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان حمدتي
تقارير اخرى تشير الى ان دارفور قد تكون
ملاذا امنا في حال استمرت المعارك حيث
يتمتع هناك بنفوذ وسيطره ربما لا يتوفران
لديه في الخرطومه يكتفي كل من البرهان
وحميتي بالحديث الى وسائل الاعلام هاتفيا
وعلى مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ينقل
البرهان تصريحاته نصا عبر الصفحات الرسميه
للجيش السوداني بينما يلجا الى النصر عبر
حساباته على تويتر وفيسبوك
[موسيقى]
بينما تدور حرب شرسه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوه الدعم السريع والى جانب توابع تلك
الحرب على المدنيين يخشى كثيرون من تاثر
العام الدراسي الحالي سلبا اذا ما استمرت
هذه الحرب لفتره ما بعد عيد الفطر وهو
الموعد المقرر لجلوس بعض الفصول الدراسيه
للامتحانات النهائيه
مره اخرى يقاد السودان الى طريق التيه
ويطارد الموت الملاحقين منذ سنوات من اهله
بالخوف والجوع ولم تكتفي الحرب السودانيه
بما تحققه من خراب لتقرر المساهمه بخراب
التعليم عبر ضرباتها
من هذه الفتحه في احد اسوار هذه الجامعه
يخرج هؤلاء الطلبه الى حياه ابخست الحرب
منها وهي تنشر القتل في احياء السودان
وشوارعه وصولا الى تلك الجامعه عبر رصاصه
طائشه ازهقت روح واحد من الطلاب
مدارس وجامعات تاثرت بضربات الحرب ولقيت
ثلاثه تلاميذ مصرعهم نتيجه سقوط قذيفه
بالقرب من منزلهم بمنطقه شرق النيل مستقبل
عام دراسي ينتظر جلوس اكثر من 500 الف
طالب وطالبه لامتحانات الشهاده السودانيه
يثير القلق على مصيره لو استمرت المعارك
لايام
لكن هناك طلبه قرروا هجره الكتب والمدارس
بعد ان دمرت منازلهم واخطعت الحرب اهاليهم
على طرق درب النزوح حرب السودان كغيرها من
حروب عاشتها المنطقه تثبت بدورها ان
الاطفال والطلاب يبقون الخاسر الاكبر
ودافع الضريبه الاعلى عندما ينزلق قاده
الدول لحروب داخليه قد لا تبقي ولا تذر
مشكله المياه الحقيقه مشكله كبيره نازله
عن انه على سبيله الناس ما لاقي يعني حتى
الموت الصحفي محلات التجاريه
استخدموا الابار الجوفيه والمعانة كبيره
جدا
يتم استخدامك
بعد 48 ساعه من سيطره الجيش السوداني على
مطار وقاعده مرواوي شماليه السودان زميلنا
نزار بقداوي الصحابه كاميرا العربيه بجوله
داخل المطار ورصد الاضرار حيث تضرر برج
المراقبه بشكل كبير شراء الاشتباكات بين
الجيش والدعم السريع الجديد باننا الان
داخل هذا المطار وداخل القاعده العسكريه
العملياتيه في مدينه مروي هذا هو برج
المراقبه الرئيس للقاعده وللمطار هذا
البرج الذي كنا يوم امس في هذه النقطه وقد
عاكسنا حجم الضرر الذي لحق به
هذه الاجهزه
اجهزه التواصل والاتصال
يبدو انها مدمره بالكامل
واستقبال الطائرات
عبر اجهزه الرادار محمد بالنسبه
هنا هذه الصور لهذه الاجهزه اللاسلكيه
يبدو انها خارج الخدمات امام الان
كالنتيجه اشتباكات حصلت في هذه المواقع ام
تدمير للعناصر الدعم السريع ربما التي
كانت موجوده قبل انسحابها ماذا يقول
هو مؤكد خالد
المطروحه الان بان الاشتباكات كانت عنيفه
كل ما يحدث من ضرر هو نتيجه لهذا
الاشتباكات نتيجه للقصف العنيف الذي شهدته
هذه المنطقه
هذا ما يمكن ان نؤكد عليه بان الضرر وقع
نتيجه لعمل عسكري كانت هذه المنطقه من
المطار
مسرحا
وكانت ارضيه لكل العمليات العسكريه القصف
المدفعي القصف العنيف
حجم الضرر
هذا الدمار الذي لحق بالمطار لحق بالقاعده
لحق بهذا البرج لهذه القاعده وهذا المطار
الذي يمثل احد اهم المطارات في المنطقه
الاقليميه لانه يطل على الاتجاه الشمالي
للسودان على حدود السودان مع دوله مصر
منهم مباشره يمكن ان يتم التنسيق كما فعل
مسبقا الجيش السوداني مع عدد من جيوش
الدول في المنطقه الاقليميه
ايضا يعتبر هذا المطار بديلا لمطار
الخرطوم الدولي اذا ما حدثت اي متغيرات في
مطار الخرطوم يتم الاستعانه بهذا المطار
[موسيقى]
وفي نهايه هذه الساعه هذا موجز لاهم
الاخبار المتفرقه حيث اعلنت المحكمه
العليا في السعوديه عن ان عيد الفطر يوم
الجمعه وذلك بعد ان تمت رؤيه الهلال في
مرصداي تمير وحطط سدير وذلك وفق ما نقلت
ديوان الملكي والسعودي كما اعلنت الامارات
وقطر وعدد من الدول العربيه والاسلاميه عن
ان الجمعه غره شهر شوال اي اول ايام عيد
الفطر اعاده الله على الجميع باليمن
والبركات
ادرجت الحكومه السويسريه مجموعه فاجنرال
العسكريه الخاصه ووكاله الانباء
الفيدراليه الروسيه ريافان على قائمه
العقوبات ضد روسيا وجاء في بيان وشراء على
موقع الحكومه السويسريه ان اداره شؤون
الاقتصاديه والتعليم والابحاث المسؤوله عن
العقوبات والساعات قائمه العقوبات ضد
روسيا وان العقوبات ستدخل حيز التنفيذ
اليوم الخميس بدءا من الساعه السابعه
بتوقيت المحليه لموسكو
اكد الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي اثناء
زياره الى كيف اكد ان اولويه الحلف هي
تتمثل بضمان تغلب اوكرانيا في الحرب على
روسيا وقال بان مستقبله اوكرانيا هو داخل
العائله الاوروبيه الاطلسيه وسيتم بحث خطه
انضمامها للناتو خلال القمه التي ستعقد في
شهر يوليو
قال الرئيس الاوكراني
الوقت حان لي دعوه للانضمام الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي والاتخاذ القرار المناسب بحسب
قوله جاء هذا في اطار اول زياره يقوم بها
الامين العام لحلف الناتو الى والتي تندرج
ضمن مساعيه لمواصلتي دعم اوكرانيا
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها نفذت
10 طلعات جويه لدعم وحدات الهجوم
فيروس
وتمكنت من تدمير مقر قياديه اوكرانيه على
الجبهه واشارت الى ان مدفعيه مجموعه او
مدفعيه مجموعه القوات نفذت 64 مهمه قصف
ومنعت القوات الاوكرانيه من القيام بهجوم
مضاد
في خبر اخر اعلن ديمتريبيسقوف المتحدث
باسم كريم انا ترى سنتين النوويتين لفرنسا
وبريطانيا هما تحت سيطره الولايات المتحده
ويجب تخفيضهما وقال بسكوف انهم اذا تحدثوا
للولايات المتحده دون مراعات هاتين اثر
سنتين فلا معنى لاي محادثات خاصه ان فرنسا
وبريطانيا نظام متكامل لحلفانات الخاضع
لسيطره الولايات المتحده بحسب قوله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذه الساعه انتهت ولكن تغطيه العربيه
للاوضاع في داخل السوداني نزلت مستمره
مشاهدينا بعد قليل تستكمل معكم هذه
التغطيه الزميله منتهى الرمحي اليك منتهى
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات